why don't you do what you do what to do
what to do why don't you do what you do
what to do what you do
[Music]
thanks for coming to the LCDs support
group next up is the bipolar group I
know we have a lot of overlap thank you
hi I'm Myra by the way oh hi I'm Gina
nice to meet you
are you staying for the next one by any
chance probably I really liked what you
had to say about picturing your boobies
breasts every time a guy goes down in
you I totally relate as you might have
heard I have some issues with my grandpa
incest OCD yeah that's just the one I
can talk about Hey look I'm at this dog
shelter and for some reason like the
only thing I can even picture - yeah
exactly and sometimes it's like the ugly
dogs it's smell the worst right it's
always the worst dogs I never I would
love to be attracted to like a
good-looking dog just once I love that
part of your head so much I don't know
what I would do without you
thanks Ari
oh that's cool um I just got invited to
this feminist talk in New York they want
women of all different ages to discuss
female circumcision for an all-male
audience I think it's gonna be like
super cool honey when do you leave me oh
I don't know probably like a week or
something and for how long five days I
mean you there's a lot to see anywhere
la can happen in five days
[Music]
Oh
so much couldn't wait to make me dinner
and tell me everything don't be okay
all right well that's getting late and I
have to work no don't leave I have to or
we're talking at preschool is today
about sexual harassment in the classroom
it's an issue all right well I'll see
you later
No
no don't leave I need you too much no
can I get up please please no you can't
you can only get up he promised about
weave I need you to let go no I'm in
love with you you have to stay I'm not
letting go
let go I have an iron grip of love she
didn't know you're hurting my arm
no you can't leave me please don't leave
me if you don't let go and calling the
police I'll call the cops and tell them
to stay away I don't care
will you come with me No
[Music]